اوقاتكم اهلا وسهلا بكم في حوار فرانس 24
نحن في جزيره جربه نحن في افتتاح قمه
الفرنكوفونيه في للمره الاولى في بلد
مغربي وضيفنا يتحدث اللغه الفرنسيه يتحدث
اللغه العربيه ويتحدث اللغه الانجليزيه
ضيفنا هو رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد افريقيا
السيد موسى فقيه اهلا وسهلا بك على قناه
اهلا وسهلا
الافريقيه وقمه الفرانفونيه تنعقد في بلد
افريقي في شمال افريقيا سعيد بذلك
انت في هذه الجزيره الجميله
تونس ونحن مسرورين
لتواجدنا في تونس وحضور هذه هذا المؤتمر
مؤتمر الفرانكو
طيب نحن افارقه لنا شق عربي اريد ان احدثك
عن العديد من المواضيع الساخنه خاصه
بدرجه الاولى على السودان
وكان الامور تدور في حلقه مفرغه منذ فتره
طويله ما الذي يمكن القيام به
لتحريك هذه العمليه والله كما قلت مع
الاسف الامور تدور في السودان انت تعرف
الاتحاد الافريقي في 2019 لعب دور محوري
متوصلنا على اتفاق ولكن مع الاسف
صار انقلاب في اكتوبر
2021 ولحد الان الامور تدور
عاد الاتحاد الافريقي ونشط
اليه ثلاثيه مع الامم المتحده ومع منظمه
الايجاد منظمه الجهويه لغرب لشرق افريقيا
ونحن نقابه التقدمات لكن بصراحه همم الوضع
في السودان متازم
والساسه
متفرقين
ومن الضروره ان نجد همم كيفيه لحل هذه
المشكله في هذا البلد المهم الطور هناك
ارضيه بين المكون العسكري والمكون المدني
ام هناك حوار طرشان حسب رايك
في البدايه همم
اتفاق مع الاطراف ان نوحد اولا الجانب
المدني
نجد سيغه وبعد ذلك يتحاور مع مع الجانب
العسكري
لا اقول جهه ما لكن كل الاطراف لها
مسؤوليه وخاصه التدخلات الاجنبيه ايضا في
شان السوداني الزمن الموضوع فلابد اخوتنا
في السودان ان يكون
[موسيقى]
لان هم
الذين يحللون
تتحدث عن تدخلات اجنبي
ان يلعب السودانيون ورقه الاتحاد الافريقي
ربما كنا نتوصل الى ما تم التوصل اليه في
البدايه وهو كان
اجنده خاصه
ان السودانيين هم اهل القرار فنسهل فقط
ولا مفرد رؤيه ولا جلده ما للسودانيين اهل
السودان ادرى بحالهم من كل من كل شخص اخر
وهم قادرين على حل المسالهم فلهم ان يكون
يقين ويهتم ببلتهم السودان ببلد عظيم جدا
طبعا نحن على بعض 200 كيلو متر تقريبا من
ليبيا بلد مجاور نعم وتونس هي من الدول
التي تاثر بما يجري في ليبيا الوضع في
ليبيا
يعني ضبابي بالنسبه لكثيرين
الاتحاد الافريقي يحاول ان يلعب دور هل
هناك اذان صاغيه في ليبيا لما يريد
الاتحاد الافريقي لهذا البلد
في البدايه لكن حاليا اقدر اقول
في ليبيا يستمعون الاتحاد
متاكدين انها هي الاساس
ولذلك
ارسل للرئيس ساسو
وارسلنا انا وهو
وزير خارجيه الكونغو ومدير مكتب عده مرات
هذه الايام رجعوا الى جربه قادمين من من
طرابلس
حاليا نعمل
الاجتماع تمهيدي لمؤتمر للمصالح الوطنيه
نتكلم مع كل الاطراف
في الغرب في الشرق في الوسط في الجنوب
المهم ان
الممثلين الشعب الليبي
يجدون فرصه ليتحاوروا بعضهم لذلك نحن نفضل
المصالحه لان هي ممكن تفتح الباب لاتفاق
سياسي
في هذا البلد الشقيق طيب افهم من كلامك ان
الامم المتحده وكانها انسحبت كليا من
ليبيا بعد ان فشلت في كل المحاوله
[موسيقى]
في في هذه الايام سيد عبد الله
للاميين العام ونحن نعمل الامه
نعم نعم منذ ان وصل السنغالي
في نوع من الدفه الجديده لعمليه سياسيه في
في ليبيا ويتضمن عده مراحل ونحن كلفنا
بالمرحله الاساسيه وهي المصالح الوطنيه
جنوب يذهب الى الشرق يذهب الى الغرب يزور
كل المدن صحيح نعم وهناك تجاوب من كل
الاطراف
ان في التجاوب
اظن اخوتنا اللي بين صراحه همم ملوا زي ما
بيقولوا هناك مملو من من كثره المشاكل
وجاء الوقت للحل لبيعانه بجوارها عانى
والغاره عانت من هذه الحاله فلا بد ان نجد
صيغه تسمح لليدين ان يتصالحوا وبعد ذلك
يمشي الانتخابات
على راس المفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي بكل
هذه المشاكل الموجوده في القاره الافريقيه
يعني كيف يمكن ان تركز في كل الاتجاهات
لكل هذه الازمات انقلابات مشاكل سياسيه في
كل مكان صعب جدا جدا
فلا بد ان نتعامل بجديه مع مع كل الاطراف
واظن في الراي الافريقي والعربي همم
انسجام
فلابد لنا ان نحل مساكنه بانفسنا هذا
حقيقه يثبتها التاريخ
والحاضر بالاخص طيب الرئاسه الدوليه
للسنغال الاتحاد للاتحاد الافريقي تسهل
ماموريه متفقين
[موسيقى]
الدوري الاتحاد
لان الهدف معروف
وانا فتحت طبعا اعمل مع رؤساء من اجل
تنفيذ الاجنده الافريقيه خاصه في السلم
والتنميه
الافريقي في عهدك
اصبحت له كلمه لدى المنظمات الدوليه
الاخرى له راي وهذا الراي مسموع
والله
المفروض انتم اللي تغيبوا ماذا قمت به
ولكن بصراحه
تنظيم
في في افريقيا
ويمثل صوت هذه القاره والمنظمات الاقليميه
الموجوده مثل سيده مثل السمات هناك بدانا
التنسيق بدا التنسيق لان هنا بعمليه اصلاح
داخل المنظومه وهذه المنظمه الجويه لها
دور اساسي فلا بد ان نعمل همم
الفريق التي احلم بها
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]